So having seen the need for total order and
an ambiguous decision making in the distributed system let's now
introduce Lamport's Total Order formulation. This is the notation we're
going to use for Lamport's Total Order. And so what we
are saying here is that if there are two
events A and B in the distributed system, A happens
to be an event in this case on PI And
B happens to be an event, on process PJ. If
we want to assert that, a totally is ordered
ahead of b, that is a precedes b in the total order. This
is true only under the condition that either, the time stamp
associated with A is less than B or the time stamp
happens to be the same and there is some arbitrary other
function that helps us to un ambiguously decide
which event precedes the other and for instance I might say that
the process ID that I associated with PI and PJ, that maybe
the one that I use to break the tie. In my family car example, I told
you that the seniority of the family member
makes the decision in terms of how we break
the tie. So for instance in this, in this
case if process Pi has a process ID 100
and process Pj has a process ID 200 then
we could say that the arbitrary decision making in the
case of a tie is that whichever process has
a lower process ID, that's going to be the winner. So
we might, we might decide that in this case,
if time stamp happens to be the same, then since
Pi is less than Pj, I'm going to say that
a preceeds b. So it's an arbitrary, well-known condition
for breaking a tie. So every process in the
entire distributive system is going to use the same well-known, arbitrary
condition in order to break to tie. So that
also brings up another interesting point, and that is there
is no single total order. The single total order
comes from the choice of the arbitraty well known condition.
I gave you the example of my family car,
we broke the tie in the family car situation
by saying that the seniority is the winner. Tomorrow
as a family we could make the decision that the
youngest person is going to win. In that case, my
daughter will have dibs over the car over everybody
else in the case of a tie. The other
important point to understand is that all of this idea
of associating logical time stamps with events, and
then deriving a total order from the logical time
stamp using this kind of a, a method
of saying we going to just believe the time stamp
associated with the respective events. We going to believe
that time standard are associated with the events and
use those time stand as a way of
ordering them, so that we can develop total order.
And if it happens to be a tie, everybody
uses a well known arbitrary condition to break the tie
and that's how we derive a total order, and
once we have derived the total order, the time stamps
are meaningless after that. We don't care about them
anymore. The whole idea of having these logical time stamps.
Creating a partial order. And from the partial order
deriving a total order using this formulation. For total ordering.
Is so that we can get a particular total order.
And once we get the total order, timestamps are meaningless.